Shaquille O'Neal joins us here on the
Rich Eisen show because Shaquille you
know I can't have a show without you
know how are you doing my man that
Marshall Faulk I know that last anywhere
without Jesus daddy are you doing I'm
good man I'm good I'm good what's going
on man I'm just trying to make a break
that's what I'm saying the usual same to
you thank you very much' kill what's
your favorite Christmas tradition that
you have in the O'Neill household well
my favorite tradition is being able to
take care of hundreds of thousands of
kids on Laurel I realized that on
Christmas morning 15 or 20 million kids
will wake up with not one single gift I
try to put a dent in that I said I
suppose every big-time a great rapper
politician businessman he just take care
of would clear view from your your
neighborhood Boys and Girls Club will it
be a better place this year I didn't
lanta been ruled milk New Jersey Orlando
for all the Las Vegas and I like so you
know being able to buy toys kids and
have them smile is a good thing and um
all my crazy tours up a good toys in the
jindal switches iPads bikes you know
phones all the stuff that the kids may I
don't really I don't really receive
stuff for Christmas my kids are older so
Marsha you know there's there's only one
presence they want their bank account
info you know my kids are smart
negotiators they always start up and I
have to you know bring them down in the
middle somewhere he knows she killed
there's a young if you're looking for
real estate there's a house in
Washington DC it's a big house it's
white
I think the address is 1600 there's got
big bedrooms they've got tall ceilings
maybe that'd be a good place for you to
go and take up shop in 2020 I don't do
politics you know that I know like you -
I would like you to that would be nice
let's talk for a second about the game
that we saw last night we saw a big man
walk
Jonas and Yanis and Shaquille what did
you see when you saw him last night five
three-pointers when you say jaan is
strutting in the floor we have talked a
lot especially last year when I talked
to you a lot for the Lakers stuff but
when you see this giant man striding
down the court the Revenge of the seven
footers what was your what was your
thought last night and watching him play
I saw a guy that all kids who were they
to what I mean but I he wasn't a high
draft pick when he was fifteen sixteen
sixteen yeah he was named a top ten
player when he drafted that black
because of hard work because of
perseverance because of him believing
that he's the best player in the world
he's here now and he's putting everybody
on notice and you know what we all love
about sports actually Marshall and
muscle van uses you've been around long
time it's all about competition I love
competition I would listen to Braun been
a man for a long time but at some point
he's either gonna go away on this old or
one of those youngsters I think I'm
doing okay I know you the King but then
you decaying what am i and you know he
came out and played and he showed this
game last night because I'm sure this
guy report is to back off back off of
him and you know when Anthony Davis got
on be the one that gave up on fall so he
backed up he was I guess what I've been
working on my game and he shot five
threes
I don't like him shooting threes but
they gonna go in keep shooting big
minutes and he's you know he's making
making a case for you know the best game
to say that then check because we're
looking at the numbers we're looking at
looking at this kid at where you know
LeBron 35 he's 25 when we saw moments
last night where it felt like highs
there are a torch being passed are we
reading into that too early well it
depends on your definition of torch
definition of course meters you got to
get that gold ball at your house you
know I know he's the MVP and he fell
short and when it comes to being one of
the best players in the game years but
you know what makes LeBron greatest he
makes all the players around great and
he's won the time so you know I know you
didn't win last year but the fact that
he has three rings still gives him the B
hierarchy over you know all the other
players that
coming up number two will probably have
to be Kauai I know you don't say KB and
step but they're not really flying this
year so you can't really count them so
it's LeBron Kauai and then the honest
and then James are the models actually
no scratching for that position but you
know another good thing about
competition is you know the way people
see it you know some people are just say
he's the best some people say no LeBrons
of us I love these conversations because
these conversations just you know makes
it better for the game
you know Marshall like you know us it
was the best running back this bad
hearing didn't yeah we did that you know
like my talking about Lamar Jackson I
love the margins I think he's the best
but you got some guys out there said no
no he ain't the best year and I know
he's doing what Michael Vick did and all
that but he ain't won nothing yet and
all that and all that so I just sit back
and listen because it's what we've been
doing all our life makes for great TV it
makes for great video now when you when
you look at Yanis and I you know I just
I keep contemplating this now he might
overtake LeBron as when you think about
the player that that the fans love
watching and all of that but I'm trying
to figure out in Milwaukee can Yanis by
himself compete with the Clippers or
with the Lakers alright I just don't I
just don't think one guy and some others
can do with these multiple superstar
teams are doing how long a minute you
been friends Marshall oh my god since I
was like 18 19 alright so don't don't
you ever ask my question with your radio
voice put some basis in you intelligent
man you great question it would be a
great story if he could as you know when
it comes to playing a team sport
Diaw was always going to have to step up
the way he's playing right now he's
given them confidence and if they can
step up like they step up last night
they do have a shot of course you're
gonna need that second score their
second score is men
so owners of the pressures on here
Shaquille O'Neal joins us here on the
rich Iser show the playoffs last year
middleton disappeared in the playoffs he
disappeared in the playoffs I keep
watching them I don't like I don't think
that there are others when you get into
playoffs he and you got you know it's
it's seven games I don't know where
those others can show up cuz Yanis gonna
win probably one of those four that they
need to win the others all those other
teams that's gonna be in the hunt
they're going to make the others beat
them you heard it here first if the
others don't step up
Yanis a monster oh my god did they step
up they win they go further they win a
championship I'm just gonna be a
Milwaukee brother but if they know you
don't step up and you get people to
putting stuff in his ear maybe we need
to go here man you know that
who knows what happened Obama other from
Kyle Korver every time you kid to tell
me I'm gonna knock it down for Shaquille
O'Neal here on the Rich Eisen show Suzie
Shuster Marshall Faulk but do you really
think that Yanis will stay in the walk
you regardless I mean there's beaches to
be had there's life to be had is it
really all there is to win because let's
face it nobody knows about living big in
a city more than you do
yeah but all they went to that city
because they paid me maximum dollars
okay so you know you just don't have to
take care of the business of basketball
the way is set up now no walk he can pay
him the house and you know for him with
these new numbers they passing around I
think they call them threesome what you
think Marshall did I they gonna max it
out like whatever so whatever the most
they can give him the kid he's proven to
me and I think everybody that watches
basketball that he's not afraid of doing
the work to get better 300 main in
Milwaukee calm stretch a lot further
than 300 million in LA yeah 300 million
in Milwaukee is similar to 300 million
Miami 300 million in Canada ain't
nothing compared to 300 million in
California so he's gonna have to look at
the business the basketball and really
what and you know these days you know
they talk about you need to be in the
bigger market the bigger market is on
your phone it's called social media if
you a guy that everybody wants to see
you don't need to live in a big city to
you know get to notoriety
you got to notoriety in the palm of your
hand is called social media Shaquille
O'Neal joins us here on the Rich Eisen
show she killed before I asked you more
about the Clippers who lost to the
Rockets last night have you ever seen a
player in the middle of a game stop a
game and start measuring a hoop it's
called it's called marketing and get
people to look at you 20 years.i silly
stuff just to get people to laugh that's
marketing so everyone's gonna take a
little look at Russell Westbrook what
about the Clippers I mean we talked
about that Marshall and I have said it's
hard to even recognize this team with a
new look the new colors the new font
they've been put together very very well
what are your thoughts on the Clippers
the first team I've seen with a double
one-two punch you got Kawhi and Paul
George with on that first one and then
you got Lou Williams and Bart says
Harrell coming off the bench a vision
walked in that day I don't think I've
ever seen that at the team before and
they hang that on defense
you know Eli's the last James you know
what should be for both before Toronto
Golden State they had a lot of scores
but they also hung the head on defense
so it's gonna be gonna be fun and I like
but I hate when people ask the question
if the Clippers win wasn't your clipper
town the answer is I can't say on the
Rich Eisen show but the word starts with
that I mean what I can't stand watching
as somebody who's known you for so long
as when people like to say to you like
hey Shaquille are they the little fellas
with the big fellas because I've heard
it's like guys think of an original
question I mean how many times can you
possibly be asked are they the little
fella right the little brothers in the
locker room and they always say that in
the faking no I got a question for you
give me give me a surprise team like a
team that's kind of under the radar like
that could that could actually make some
noise or they might be like maybe maybe
they might be a piece away those those
two guys can can get their act
consistently together
not that it's a problem but you know
when you're a player like Joelle you
should already know what it takes to be
great because we're already telling you
you're great you can't have lapses it's
like we're going for a thousand yards in
one year and then actually come back and
go for 300 yards no concern no better
than that we don't jump on you don't be
like hey man you want the best runner
back ever
kierra outside do those herky-jerky
moves you do and give us some yards so
the fact that we we had the jump on him
the other day you know to get him like
to get on track she should already know
that he should already want that Yanis
once that he knows that no we don't have
to say nothing by galaxy players are
every play he works on this game I like
the fact he said now I'm not joining up
another superstar and I'm not working
out with Austin superstar I'm gonna
become the best I'm how are you gonna
rip joint what's happening here it
sounds like you're cooking in the
background yeah some of my kitchen you
are what are you making what am I making
I'm making some spareribs some lamb
chops some macaroni cheese it's
encouraging so it's a late day for you
cooking show coming up and I buy
award-winning chef Alex Conan's will
show me how to prepare dishes cooking
show coming out March is called in the
kitchen with Jack what yeah this is
breaking news we have any breaking news
music I mean are you kidding me what
can't you do
well this is my I'm coming out with a
lot of a lot of products that that will
be
be easier for people to cook so are you
actually cooking this or somebody else
cooking and you're just standing there
I'll be there you'll see I can't wait to
see this I mean I'm just thinking that
maybe Marshall you and I ought to hop on
the first flight out of here and
actually get some rent I'm just taking
you know in being in Texas the time he
spent in Baton Rouge dad he can put some
dishes together okay what's the best
thing that you can make rich can make
scrambled eggs that's it Wow
and a really good drink the best thing I
can make now is smack rum and souffle no
smack Roman okay Top Ramen but I call it
smack rum it's gonna make you smack yeah
but if you're a marketing guy it could
be it should be called Shaq ramen right
shouldn't it be isn't that trademarked
actually you know what thank you I'll
give you three point nine percent if we
have a drop that brother Shakeel I've
been holding your ass up for so long
it's about time I got something from it
I'm just saying you know it's been a lot
of years give me a point a percent
that's all I'm asking for Christmas is
three point nine percent I think guys
going somewhere good jobs in work what
do you got for a real commercial Shaq so
Marshall uh I think they gave the
Heisman out too early Joe Budden is the
Heisman but when you get get in this
late in the playoffs and all this stuff
and you're already gonna play a team
that's great you don't want to give them
no extra ammunition exactly so when they
play Oklahoma who already has the tough
defense rule week this game next week
gonna be crazy I think yeah I think
they're gonna say okay
Heisman all right we'll see watch this
and then you know that you lose that
game and you know we we don't get to
play clay in the play in the national
national championship game the end they
play Oklahoma who who their plan
Oklahoma
Oklahoma that know them Oh Jeremy hurt
Jalen hurts he's very familiar with with
uh with the defensive coordinator and
the defense I think they're sure to have
to find a forty good London Heisman yeah
that's why the Heisman Trophy winner and
a national championship it's rare that
they're on the same team it's very
Shaquille Merry Christmas I love you as
always all right where's rich he is in
Tampa Bay calling the Bucks game
tomorrow yeah he's got the Texans bucks
tomorrow
so you'll see him on the air then a wing
back and do the sunday show but let's do
a little face time after this so I can
see this food and imma see your party
down in Miami - okay cool oh yeah yeah
me too much love Merry Christmas thanks
to you for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app